bonjour et bienvenue dans le studio
diagonale tv spéciale championnat de
france à juin 2016 aujourd'hui je suis
avec une super championne c'est natacha
benmesbah bonjour natacha alors cette
année c'est une belle saison pour toi
parce que tu as fini un championnat
universitaire sur le podium
oui j'ai fini troisième c'était en
janvier à strasbourg
oui le niveau était assez relevé c'est
un mixte ainsi offert un chèque n'est
donc ça c'est important je crois qu'il
ya d'autres tu m'as dit il yad'autres
féminines qui ont réussi dans ce tournoi
mixte aussi à gagner à réussir un podium
voire même à gagner quoi il me semble
que ce qui me semble c'est sûr narry ces
vagues et mathilde conjugaux ont déjà
été championne de france universitaire
mixte pas mal donc tu étais un peu sur
leurs traces bon tu finis 3e c'est pas
championne mais c'est quand même
chouette quoi la prochaine fois on fera
donc voilà maintenant en universitaire
les filles challenge les gars avec les
podiums et des titres donc voilà donc
c'est vrai 'cependant chouette alors
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire d'autre
tu as tu as fait une belle saison aussi
en club en tournoi tu as fait ton la
dernière manche jouer l'open de pondre
où il y avait un tour de maître
international fermé oui
autrement j'ai fait des partis par
équipe et c'est tout cette année j'ai
pas eu l'occasion de beaucoup jouer aux
durs qu'a toujours ton activité quand
même de d'études
ici tu es tu en études de médecine et
puis donc et c'est du boulot ça oui bien
sûr j'ai un concours d'internât préparer
alors ce championnat tu as démarré quand
même assez difficilement réussi vraiment
à décoller saâd à enchaîner des
résultats un peu un peu tendu mais bon
alors hier tu as eu à bénéficier d'un
concours de circonstances on peu
spéciale puisqu'elle mira a dû déclarer
forfait mais toi c'est de fait quand
même un point et puis aujourd'hui par
contre tu réussi une très belle partie
et donc ça trop lance dans ce
championnat
oui ça me permet aussi de me remettre un
peu en confiance
oui parce que même si j'ai marqué un
point sur les trois premières parties
disons que la première g andrea
boulanger qui me donne une tour en un
coup oui c'est vrai et donc là
aujourd'hui ça oui c'est vrai c'est
parti un peu plus disons un peu mieux
construites quoi en dire un peu plus
mentir alors surtout face à ninon que
comme la vision tour de france qui se
rend plus de deux titres de championne
de france avant donc qui était quand
même qui est quand même dans une série
longue de domination mais l aurais tu
réussi une très belle partie
alors on va peut-être voir cette partie
donc tu as les blancs oui et c'est parti
avec 1 4 donc c'est sûr ton qu'on
favorise ça oui je veux que quatre
premiers coups voilà comme ça s'est fait
comme fischer judit polgar aussi d'un
sixième année je crois joué quasiment
tout le temps 4 c'est un très bon coup
je suis d'accord donc c'est ça hein tu
t'attendais à ça oui et non pas de
problème donc cavalier f3 scola c'est
normal qu'à blesser 6 pas de surprise
elle vous a joué 6 e 6 non j'avais
préparé quelque chose sur ie6 et j'avais
regardé rapidement la ressource d'accord
et rossel voilà sur k et ses six fours
b1 qui ma cour mais d'ailleurs boum
quand même oui voilà donc c'est alors
fou b5 alors tu avais joué d'ailleurs tu
vas jouer s'il me semble bien cette
ouverture au préalablement et c'est sûr
et après tu étais revenu dans le dos oui
c'est ça en décembre
tu as fait une partie sur quoi aussi
c'est l'avant-dernière stern l'an
dernier c'est ça oh non c'est pas cette
année où tu ajoutes revenus d'accord je
me trompe pas là non c'était pas cette
ouverture d'accord donc ici des six
normales
oui on joue plutôt aussi sous signe un
décès se joue 6 g6 où se joue donc avait
prévu salle
elle a déjà joué cette ouverture la
gauche et donc petit rock food et sept
tours et maintenant qu'elles agissent
tout ça semble assez normal n'y a pas
trop de commentaires à faire ces
théories oui n'était pas surprise on
peut dire un nom du tout et la c3 ça
c'est ça c'est spécial parce qu'on peut
jouer aussi des quatre sans doute
non me semble que ces trois c'est le
clou si le meilleur oui d'accord ok l'a6
et la voilà donc là que tu leur
reviennent bien la maison on est
d'accord donc finalement tu sors le fou
pour revenir
ouais anouk l'idée c'est pouvoir comme
comme dans la suite de la partie on va
voir jouer des 4 on n'a pas peur du
courage à angers 4 on n'a pas peur du
tout âge ici
elle a joué fou g4 elle a quand même pu
louer ce n'est pas grave on joue quand
même des quatre quand même ah oui alors
là où on s'était posé la question parce
qu'après prise prise
on pourrait éventuellement prendre un f3
ici la prise en f3 sur l'a13 en f3 alors
admettons qu'il est pris dans les trois
caisses qui s'est on bosse que rompt
avec la plongée
si je reprends de la dame et je vais le
problème évidemment ils repèrent le tir
oui mais c'est grave non n'a pas d'ordre
étions donc ici d'opium pranger 3
d'accord et l'idée c'est qu'on a force
entre deux pions la paire de fou si les
noirs font petit rock on pourra toujours
jouer avec roy h un tour g1 wesh m sur
la possibilité d'avoir la colonne la
colonne gbla collège est d'accord donc
au final c'est tout vert 7 ce doublage
depuis on ramène un pion vers le centre
donc ça couine solide ton centre et puis
ça donne la colonne j'ai plus la paire
de fou donc c'est largement compensé un
poil rock c'est une faiblesse mais en
fait ce mouvement là pas toujours c'est
plutôt une force c'est plus dans cette
position d'accord donc finalement le
fais pas ça elles se trompent pas ça se
trouve pas loin depuis le faire aussi
mais disons que c'est disons que ça
transposerait
elle c'est une scène qui est intéressant
parce qu'évidemment comme lecavalier
cloud et on se dit qu'effectivement ils
payeront une faiblesse sur scène sur des
quatre d'accord donc ça c'est tu
t'attendais quand même à sarm si oui ça
décès partie des choses que déjà quitté
quand même préparé ça oui c'était pas en
dehors de n'importe où le dit quand on
dort en taxi à un moment donné tu vas
sortir de ta préparation serait bien sûr
donc ici des 5,5 et forcément le coup
logique caïds et 4k leurs biens une
façon là quand j'ai joué des quatre ces
trois des quatre j'ai accepté le clouage
du du cavalier on a donc avalé par le
fou une tout à fait et de me faire
doubler les pions sur la colonne est
donc tu l'avait acceptée mentalement
déjà et donc pas de problème ça me
dérangeait pas du tout voilà tu étais
pas tu avais pas de souci avec ça donc
fou 3 et là tu te poses la question car
il y est bien sûr parce que là
maintenant la menace c'est de prendre en
d4 et de gagner en option donc elle n'a
pas le choix parce que si elle prend du
fou d'ailleurs ici c'est sans doute pas
bon parce que tu reprends du pion et les
cavaliers n'a plus trop de cas ils
appâtent elle peut pas partir donc tu
vas prendre ici est sans doute ce pion
il sera perdu parce qu ils trop dans le
camp blanc et on peut plus défendre
d'accord donc ici n'a pas le choix il
faut qu'elle prenne cavaliers voilà qu'à
l'époque travail forcé et cette fois
puis en train voilà on reprend donc là
tu construis ton centre ici et en double
flux alors est-ce que le fou ici
pourrait envisager ici de mirage 5
peut-être je pense pas que oui je pense
pas que ce soit
que ce soit beau sis à bab de tactique
façon il n'y a pas de tactique avec
cavaliers prend 1,4 parce qu'on a
toujours d'alain quatre échecs il ya
toujours quatre ans à 4 da cau rien tour
où il ya toujours cette manoeuvre le
problème c'est que le fou une fois en
page 5
s'il se refaire il fera il sera bloqué
il a pu de il a plus de cases et puis si
elle est si bien g6 il va buter sur la
chaîne de pioche donc c'est
difficilement envisageable donc du coup
ça explique son coup suivant elle est
venue en 17
et puis comme on a pu voir ensuite de la
partie attentionné qui avait h 4 qu'avec
4 ça lui permet aussi de pouvoir jouer
sur la cage
h3 s'en fout pourra toujours venir aussi
en b 5
le groupe a aussi valeur pour essayer de
dévier le fouet fin de la protection de
la casse g2 oui donc on voit quand des
six le fois beaucoup plus d'avenir que
quand je suis en 17e rang ont décidément
la fois beaucoup plus d'avenir quand h5
conjointe h5 dr sans doute peut-être
vous faut deux ans tout comme ça même
d'avis qu'elle ne serait même pas
incluse puisqu'elle menace pas tout de
suite aux joutes a blessé trois là et
ces trois temps qu'il a très tranquille
et puis tout d'accord très bien donc ici
à 4 alors ça c'est un coup responsable
c'est quoi l'idée de la classe a aussi
réfléchi faut baisser et le sens des
chefs ou dessins qui ont empêché
l'expansion des noirs d'après michele
changfu causé sa non discrétion mon
choix est fait tiens on va dire il tient
quand même la maison donc oui tiens la
maison certains quand même peur que si
tu fais pas trop attention l otan droits
deviennent faibles
évidemment qu'il ya des problèmes oui
d'accord donc à quatre ça prend de
l'espace avel dame ce qu'ils sont bien
l'idée des blancs parce que je me tienne
colonies si bon comme on est un peu
faible là c'est pas de ce côté là comme
en attaque et qui en plus ont investi
cette chaîne de piau sans doute trois ou
quatre des cinq qui vise les dames
oui c'est plutôt par là que ça va se
passer et les nord avec des 6,5
ouais l'aileron les lol la case f4 pour
un cavalier par exemple et dans quelle
d'accord très bien le tableau et disons
le tableau est bien
bien planté là on a le décor on a le
décor ya plus que l'action n'ont donc
qu'à mêlée à cinq
alors évidemment qu'elle achète ça peut
faire un peu peur parce que la dame peut
venir aussi en h4
et puis le cavalier en f4 bon ceci dit
il faudrait qu'elle arrive à ouvrir la
colonne aussi à col en v avec une tour
pour tout que ce soit dangereux
là j'ai hésité jouer d'amd de s'adapter
comme sortie de temps dans sa
préparation qu'en fait non là maintenant
je fais ça devient du jour appelait +32
la suite
oui je pense que je pense que si j'ai
pas regardé précisément cette variante
c'est d'abord la nôtre et parler j'ai
surtout préparer une autre variante
qu'elle a aucune jouer d'accord donc
l'âge jusqu'ici c'était ma prépa ouais
il a fait que je pense un peu réfléchir
là maintenant fallait revenir sur
l'échiquier essayer de créer quelque
chose qu'on voit là d'accord sachant que
quand on est sur ordinateur en
sous-estiment souvent l'attaquent la la
la potentielle attaque des noirs oui et
sur l'échiquier tout d'un coup on voit
des fantômes qu'elles remplissent de
festivités quand le croco et celui ci
pose a peur bien sûr donc ici tour à
trois un joli coup alors assez assez
classique de jouer ce genre de couple
une fois qu'on a joué à quatre on le
voit dans l'espagnol aussi en bois arias
à la fois on peut venir en c3 doubler
les tours sur la colonne s'est plus tard
mais aussi on peut défendre on sait
jamais donc c'est un coup c'est un bon
coup ce à un coût subtil tout l'effet
tôt dans la partie finale parce que t'as
pas encore sorti ton cavaliers non les
cavaliers je voulais lui laisser un peu
le choix schepper d2 ou en c3 ouais ou
peut-être à trois si tu bouges à tour
oui ce jour la rejoindre a cassé quatre
oui parce que à trois c4 et puis c'est
bien pour b6 maillon fou déjà oui sur ce
je vais garder aussi la possibilité
avant de censure qui avait peut-être de
mettre la dame en d2 s'ils avaient
besoin d'amendé de aussi plutôt que je
vais cahier des deux pour verrouiller la
case
f4 et puis empêcher d'un match 4 aussi
parce que du coup je voulais c'était une
idée donc la jouer g5 voilà alors ça
c'est une mine innocent c'est une bonne
idée puisque après si je mets si les
mecs à lyon 24 je ne peux plus prendre
si je prends elle prend avec le plonger
et elle a ouvert la colonne voilà qu
elle n est ouverte et j'ai quand même
quelques petits soucis entre g22 roi
risque encore des soucis laida monde
évite créer rapidement et puis en plus
la chaîne de pions ici des 6e 5e 4 par
rapport à celles à bloc
cette tour c'est pas venir en défense
ouais donc ça peut ça peut être délicat
donc ça commence à oui ça commence à
chauffer que côté droit mais on est un
peu dans un type de position je dirais
d'attac un peu estonienne là c'est à
dire que tu as le plan clair allèles
dame mais en échange tu vas devoir
essuyer un potentiel une potentielle
attaque sans voix oui donc c'est
toujours la question est-ce qu'il faut
d'abord se défendre puis attaquer ou
attaquer attaquer ont retardé la halle
attaques de l'adversaire voit la
sellette
c'est la course en course alors on y va
donc là je vais tour ces trois en fait
je voulais jouer dame b3 faire pression
d'un détroit où d'étranges êtres b3
malgré que la tour soit là non non après
après tour ces trois accords pour
achever dam des trois oui pour mettre le
fond b6 rentrée que la france est bien
sûr francis est hélas tour pénètre et
les blancs gagne on ne sait pas encore
c'est quand même les normands en à fort
potentiel d'attac elle alors en voilà
donc comme on l'a dit avant c'était
c'est la course faut pas traîner voilà
ce que si tu attends trop et que evian
tu cites a pas de contre joël dame
tu vois que subir de toute façon et puis
en plus avec une position resserrée qui
donc il faut absolument parce que si tu
attaques bien par contre les dames ici
étant donné qu'elle va jouer sans doute
j'évite les enfants sont rois et quand
même aussi une
distance voilà une faiblesse du pit a
quand même du jeu contre lui contre
d'ailleurs on peut se demander si elle
n'aurait pas dû finalement patienter
pour son attaque et faire d'abord le
petit rock pour mettre laurent 1 h 8 et
lancé son attaque ensuite du temps
perdait du temps les mails au toit était
peut-être un peu plus à l'abri quand
même oui mais faut voir si mon plan etc
dam des trois fous d66 et rapide ouais
c'est ce que par exemple pour faire un
petit rock son fouet fuite elle mettrait
ou en fils et voilà il faut le mettre
quelque part alors un os est peut-être
mais ça bloque l'arrivée de l'attaquant
il faut et cette terre petit croix je
suis tour g 8 et g et la dame
seth rogen beaucoup de temps et je pense
que j'ai quand même le temps d'arriver
ouais c'est vrai que toi ton jeu est
quand même assez rapide maintenant c'est
vrai que c'est money on peut se poser
des questions dans ceux des muses pas
simple mais sedan b 3 le tour peut
doubler aussi voilà tu peux aussi doublé
plutôt que de jouer vous les six mêmes
mais sait-on fou ans le 3 finalement
parce que on sait jamais s'il faut
éliminer une pièce henri iv oui ça peut
aider pour déjà les puristes trois
français jouer cahier des deux mois oui
qualité de aussi possible si j'ai quatre
et joué jusque toujours échangé food et
6,7 rouge et 3 arrive on a tous revenir
en jeu train si messieurs des échanges
c'est à g4 et blessures oui d'ailleurs
g4 se mettre un terme puisque cécile
même pas ce qu'il va se passer parce
qu'il ya plusieurs plans on peut venir
avec 4 avec lecavalier mais c'est pas
facile de rajouter du fou veille il
prend les cases du cavalier donc s'il va
falloir me donnait ouvrir avec g4 et ça
si on ouvre avec les quatre on donne de
l'air à la tour pour venir défendre
aussi donc à leur tour j'ai vite ça
chauffe
on sent que la pression monte des deux
côtés la haie et wash un coup
prophylactique
oui je me suis dit comme ça si ajoute
j'ai quatre peut-être que j'ai toujours
la possibilité de jouer aux six f4
ouais je sais pas si c'était à calculer
g4 efron en cas de prise qui on prend en
fait pranger est possible aussi de
pouvoir jouer f3 ouais et
il ya plus de découvertes l'euro n'est
plus directement c'est oui c'est
toujours utile d'enlever un roi de la
vis à vis ça évite les échecs et sait
jamais c'est jamais en trop donc là quel
est le cas quand même là on commence à
avoir chaud quand même parce qu'on voit
bien que j'ai 4 d'arrivée et comme le
cas il est là il ya plus de f4 donc
l'ouverture de la colonie possible la
dame venir soit angers 5 pour menacer un
matin j'ai un sens h4 avec un matt aussi
en h2 parce que tours j'ai six tours h
systemat faut avoir le coeur bien
accroché dans le clac 8e dit bon très
bien mais il faut que j'attaque vite
maintenant we do dame b tron qui si elle
joue des 9,6 je fais dame prend 17 gagne
un temps sur sa tour madame p 3c bien
attention ça tours et le temps qu'elles
ont su en attaque j'ai peut-être le
temps de doubler mais toujours de
rentrer sur est 7e pourquoi pas
sacrifier une qualité en 17
alors là on se dit qu'elle aurait dû
jouer peut-être gk tout de suite sur le
j4 contrer faire [ __ ] en f4 alors
parce que dans leur lit je dis pourquoi
parce que j'ai 4 poko parce que sinon tu
joues b6 et isle adam est obligé de
aussi d'un enjeu s'est tout d'un coup ça
va encore on peut les un cheese par
exemple mais bon c'est que ça ralentit
quand même alors si on a joué j'ai 4 en
4 ou b6 tout de suite
elle vient h4 ou voir angers 5 puisqu'il
ya toujours la menace puis on prend un
f3 est maintenant en gir donc foulée 6
est un coût qui aiderait les noirs mais
cette position
voilà et donc tu aurais fait tu m'as dit
fou il faut prendre car le premier 4 on
regarde donc vous prend 1,4 donc dans ce
cas leur aviez pas le choix faut
reprendre oui hélas eu 5
ils natacha pur jus et oui parce
qu'alors donc le la tour et en un gaz de
serre et donc à leroy ici bien sûr faut
pas oublier que les noirs un problème
aussi est excellent et blanc' attaquant
premier en fait on profite de la
position centrale centrale une journée
noire
il ya un adage qui dit fin quand on
s'attaque au centre à l'est oui il faut
réagir au centre mais c'est vrai c'est
vrai c'est vrai tout à fait ok les
plages les pièces sont plutôt bien
placés et or le problème ici est ce
qu'on peut pas et on ne pourra pas se
cacher parce que sur un échec qui est en
train de me dire ce que l'on appelle
scotchant des buts mais non parce qu'il
ya dame b6 suu kyi va à voir arriver et
c'est matt seimat parce qu'il ya plus de
15 ans fait donc oui il est mort le roi
noir la wii heureusement on rêvait
toujours par exemple les dames g5
alors imaginons d'alger scène pour les
noirs alors l'eclid et il te prends un
f3 et je m'attends vient ici le football
pourrait vite pour contrôler mais il ya
maintenant j'ai deux aussi ça fait 2
matin donc dans ce cas la dame g5 puis
en créant des six échecs l'egypte et
alors il faut aussi ce cette fois six
pions prend 1,6 alors faut six parce que
l'idée c'est que bon je te laisse
attaquer mais séparément gm at oui ça va
casser un moment j'ai plus d'échecs
et oui mais il ya ces honneurs d'attac
voilà alors qu' on prend aussi son
absolu seul coup aussi sur les d'accord
y'a peut-être faut 7 6 qui est possible
il faut regarder fawcett au regard des
fous et c'est plutôt bien d'accord
alentours premier set pour prendre cette
voie la fuite
il a tout prévu quand même alors aurait
fui et là je pensais de soi
tours c'est 7 soit d'un premier set est
liquidée en vue d'un premier set tu as
encore la menace d'un prend à huit
matches oui et puis on a toujours des
idées avec leur apprend à 8,6 roi g7 on
peut faire tourner un grand tour pour
apprendre et ya beaucoup trop de
l'intérieur alors pour garder quand même
parce que ici donc les noirs pourrait
jouer je vais en train de regarder faire
bon allez admettons les poufs prise
menace maths alors lorsqu'elle a tu
prends la tour oui quand je te demande
pas ce que je suis pas suivre anarchy
sirois 17 et peut-être d'un emprunt et
peut-être tu donnerais la dame contre la
tour d'un coup il ya quand même deux
tours de pièces alors quitte à rendre un
peu de matériel
la cour ne peut hélas tu prends le fou
oui je crois là et là il ya quand même
de plus en plus qui avança vadam ça fait
beaucoup de matériel hi fi ght menace la
planète
c'est très solide bizarrement oui bien
qu'il a damé que salar menaçant
parfaitement ya rien d'autant qu'en plus
soutien aux trois peut être pris on joue
tous les deux mais n'est pas rien comme
en fait d'accord tranquille donc tout
simplement rend la dame et on a regardé
le matériel ici bien qu'on n'ait pas
l'habitude de donner la dame on voit
bien que là ça fait quand même beaucoup
de tours de pièces des pions qui soit en
plus proche et de faire dame bon
d'accord on va dire que c'est rideau
d'accord donc on n'a pas le temps fait
de jouer j'ai quatre là de suite non ça
va trop vite
donc elles jouent un couple elle
réfléchit quand même pendant très
longtemps mais oui le moment est crucial
voilà c'est maintenant ou jamais fléchi
pendant 30 minutes pour jouer d'amd vite
c'est-à-dire qu'elles abandonnent tout
toute idée d' attaques allaient le roi
ouais autrement dit c'est foutu quoi est
elle devient passif ouais et menaces
mon jeu il fallait presque tenté j'ai 4
ans et dont même si c'est foutu chuck
est sinon préparer h5 où je sais pas
faim je pensais que le plus ou sinon
tour g6 à l'étoile est appelé à tour
j'ai si c'est peut-être là pour courage
si j'ai quatre dan h4 d'accord alors
regardons tour g6 faut regarder parce
que on va voir qu'après ça va très vite
et l'âge d'un v6 peut-être donc là as-tu
propose en échange de damas pour moi la
finale et mais est meilleur pour les
blancs oui à cause du fait que tu as la
colonne c'est le fond elle fit tilt et
tu vas donner puis 1,4 quand même bon
admettons je récupère est d'accord
admettons tour à jouer d'un v6 t'as pas
peur de dames et fils lâchement cela
d'un train mais cette dame premier set
avec la même idée un peu combien de voir
à quoi que c'est pas clair un abattoir
et un regard d'un 2006 d'un premier set
tour d'emilie tu es là c'est oui parce
que attention ça peut aller vite aussi
un tour h6 peut-être g4 derrière qui
menace d'un match 4 il peut y avoir un
math feu vert qui serait plus rapide
ouais voilà donc là tu penses qu'il faut
calculer quand même un peu est ce que
ton fou il ya toujours des idées avec
aussi faux b6 ou des six comprend des
vies à la voilà les six d'accord mais tu
enlève la possibilité de prendre le
cavalier est là alors là que font les
noirs ici ça peut faire peur quand même
faut faire attention
là c'est la course c'est la course on
met d'accord alors tu auras admettons
entourage 6 l'idée g4 damage 4 par
exemple ou peut-être un sacrifice aussi
il faut faire attention aux sacrifices
même si sa part de marché
parce que lecavalier malheureusement
mais il ya le fou il ya le faux homme
qu'il suffit apparemment défenderesse
source et on peut être que c'est un
d'accord pour menacer devenir ans et 8
assez vite c'est ça
en fait là peut-être des idées avec fo
prend des 8 et sacrifice de l'adamant 17
ha oui il faut prendre des 8es a priori
des dames prendre 17 un peu comme dans
la partie d'ailleurs avec des tours
échec
et puis peut-être un math ou si apam
attiyah et noir décide de rendre leurs
dames
d'accord on voit que tous tes pièces
noires sont sur la loi et moi j'ai
suffit de prendre les devants et
d'avancer mais thurial d'accord alors là
ce que je joue j'ai quatre os que joue
d'alger système celui-ci s'avère long si
je laisse la dame large égard d alger si
je vais jouer g4 fou prend des vite
alors vous prendre des 8
je peux prendre de pas alors je peux pas
prendre la dame il ya trop intensive et
alves à la bombe
d'accord c'est trop fort en fait ça va
trop vite donc d'un b 3 au vu de g4 cas
pas l'air de marcher
finalement elle se décide pour madame
éviter effectivement mais là il ya plus
d'attaqués donc tu te dis ça va rentrer
tout sur le quoi faut quand même rester
un peu vieillotte mais la route vous et
son erreur du coup parce que cela si
elle peut pas de se défendre
je sais pas peut-être que il fallait
quand même tenté l'attaqué et voir ça
passe ou ça casse
c'est le genre de situation où là les
bleus horizon un plan très clair on voit
très bien que une tour va rentrer sur
les castes et s'est rapidement
ouais et les nord peuvent pas rester
passifs c'est ça tombera le pion
bessette va tomber d'accord
non je comprends bien phu d'accord qu'il
faut tenter sa chance à fond il faut
tenter la sens donc là tu as fait
carrément tout simplement à 5 à 5
parce que tu veux jouer d'un v6 et sa
dame messi souffre ou messi sous ses
airs puis dame décide mais est-ce que
c'était nécessaire assène que tu voulais
pas jouer d'un v6 tout de suite ce qui
me gênait peut-être c'était si à jouer
directement avec flo et 8 est fou fou
fou pour cette hausse est ce pour jouer
faut des 8es oui oui ça a l'air bon et
alors qu'est ce que ça change par
rapport à 5 ans joint à cinq je voulais
mettre le font dessinent se mettre le
fou donc d'inscrire sur fos est fou des
buts c'est moins grave
voilà
d'accord on est aussi peut-être de m
faire cavalier d2 qui avait laissé
quatre faire pression sur les confions
d67 précise que les c4 est l'opium
contrôler toutes les cases le cavalier
peut menacer de prendre en d6 peut-être
par exemple par avec dame b46 le fou
samba où ce genre de dépression et puis
si c'est le cas on y vient d en b si
c'est pénible fin tout cas alors on voit
bien que le jeu blanc oui là c'est là je
me sentais beaucoup mieux
bah oui quand nino a joué dnp mythe tout
d'un coup on voit que la pression est là
les droits tombent
wen en rémission est là c'est juste une
question je pense de technique pour les
blancs sireuil toujours rester vigilant
parce qu'on n'est jamais à l'abri d'un
d'amd 8 d'un match 4 c'est pour ça que
quand je jouais à 5 fu b6 j'empêche la
dame d'accéder à la casse des 8es de
revenir elle pourra pas revenir en
attaque
et comme le roi et voyez est mal placée
il faudrait presque faire un euro que la
main donc fausse est donc là tu te poses
pas quel est des deux tu ramènes de la
pression une pièce qui menacent et je
voulais voir ce qu'elle allait jouer
c'est je vais food et 8 ou autre chose
d'accord peut-être jouer qui avait
laissé quatre cavaliers b6 là j'ai le
temps faim la tour en évitant la case
qui plus est en baisse east contre la
casse et 8 pour imaginer de doubler les
tours et d'aller et venir faire des
échecs là tranquille quoi voyez il
manquait plus qu'une pièce qui jouait
pas bien qu'appréciant sur déjà très
forte on se presse pas et on rajoute de
la pression tranquillement on remarque
les noms n'ont pas vraiment de
non pas du tout dans ta de jeu tout à
fait fou des 8 et la boum tranquille
devant les 6 et 6 voilà tout simplement
vous dessinez on va éliminer ce fou et
s'ils se foutant blé case noirs
deviennent faibles le cavaly cathy
vanier en c4 des systèmes va pas tenir
il a cassé cette on pourra envahir la
casse et cette eau si on peut menacer
aussi des fous ces sept on double les
tours pousser cette la dame si la dame
bouge on prend des 6 et tout tombe
et si on prend b on pénètre avec gain de
temps alors donc foulé 6-3 7-6 2 6-1
tentatives pour lier les taux finalement
donc décidé de toujours sur la défense
en fait là donc tu continues ton plan
toutes les pièces jouent maintenant
regardez c'est assez beau en termes de
d'harmonie parce que les là on à double
effectivement doubleuse d'autorité sur
la colonne la dame est en jeu le fou est
déjà dans le camp ennemi lequel des deux
états une case devenir être pénible bon
il défend en plus un peu et se fout là
il est à la fois défensif puisqu'il
empêche le cavalier de boucher et ainsi
jamais à un moment donné il pourrait
sortir à venir prendre à 6 ou je sais
pas faire un échec en bessin je ne sais
pas mais en tout cas il est il est huit
films il y six ans il est sur son
meilleur case oui sur sa case de départ
est donc ici j'ai 4 allez c'est quand
même nous voulions un peu le jeu c'est
un peu la dernière chance sinon tout
simplement fou c'est 7 pouces et 7 avec
etc a blessé quatre derrière la menace
en fait poussé cette es6 a fait pas
[ __ ] on sait cette je me lasse fou
prend des 6es d'amd 4 vous prendre des
6es d'un paravent pour regarder ça tient
imaginons qu'elle joue pas mon raciste
ou hi5 wall5 c'est un coup à cinq
lettres admettons que je joue h5 dans ce
cas là tu pourrais faire pousser cette
wii et si la dame joue par exemple en a
sept équidés d'attaquer le pire f2 et
oui et attention comment et la superbe
foot france et oui parce qu'en cas de
roy prend regardez c'est matt damon et
quatre matelots rebond peut coordonner
la dame mais c'est matt ses shows déjà
donc g4 alors là tu choisi de prendre de
prendre donc tu laisses pas fait at a
pas envie de laisser faire du rhin tu as
peur de ça quand même encore un peu pour
jouer fou h3 peut-être éliminé deux
défenseurs
oui là enfin je préfère prendre je me
dis que ma tour en c3 pas toujours à 100
g iii en plus oui
wes à perdre et de l'autre côté oui
c'est vrai ça défend on puisse y apprend
pas fait toujours des coups comme f3 ou
s3 qui consolide la préside la pression
tout à fait c'est toujours un pion donc
un jeu prendrait six ans reprend b6
maintenant la dame
alors voilà il ya plus qu' il n'y a plus
qu'à aller sur le cac c'est 7 pour tenir
tout le tout le truc
elle prend quand même angers 4 attention
attention parce que maintenant on voit
que ninon ici pourrait venir en g8 avec
la dame et il ya maintenant j'ai un et
c'est pas facile à paris bon pour encore
joué tf 37 kf3 et on veut la d'amendés 6
après le coup f3 contrôler la case hier
ah oui on peut aussi jouer g34 f3 pardon
et la dame contrerait à casion d'accord
donc même ça même si ça peut être un peu
menaçants c'est intenable d'accord donc
ici et en plus on pourrait osciller
autour g3 tout simplement oui toujours
toi j'étais pas trop m'inquiéter
il fallait juste un peu calculé pour
être sûr que pour ces sept bombes et en
menacent de prendre 17 notamment pas qu
on associe cavaillé c4 on en a aussi qui
avait laissé quatre avec d'un proche des
six et rideau durant donc qu'elle tente
la dernière petite combine dame g8 hélas
les blues jouent et gagnent en fait vous
la main ça donc on vous laisse regarder
un peu comme un vrai problème
un petit problème boîte pas très
compliqué mais bon il faut quand même le
placer voilà ta réfléchi combien de
temps là-dessus 30 secondes
non non un peu plus parce que deux
minutes la lettre si un rafale être sûr
parce qu'il ya maintenant un coup quand
même 11 et noir menace à tour g1 matin
et puis quand même on sacrifie la
qualité
donc il faut être sûr de ne pas tout à
fait bon société au même au pire tu peux
jouer 3 qui cesseront pas de médecins
m'ont mise et où reprend donc le coup
bon alors on y va tout reprend 17 e
reprend 17 tranquillou ou donne une
pièce net
si le roi s'en va voyez encore
d'apprendre des six coups sûrs ou 1,8 je
pensais tout simplement jouer f3 et
suroît 8 on joue f3 attaque la tour
propose à la dame de défendre donc on
pourrait prendre la tour et revenir en
plus en défense avec la taille puisque
on contrôle les cases blanches avec
lecavalier avec le fou il ya aucun aucun
souci donc ça c'est encore plus radicale
linois quand même prix non mais là c'est
matin après je sais c'est quasiment toi
j'ai vu j'ai gagné une pièce vous avec
les échanges et les dames
bon ok cheikh c'était suffisant pour
jouer adrian d'accord oui huit échecs
alors voir cette parce qu'il faut
pouvoir fuir
et là c'est vrai d'accord oui ben quoi
encore ceinture en ifsi ce que tu ferais
quoi toutes ces idées
elle aurait fait roi raid 6 donc là je
changerais les dames et je crois et
voilà c'est tout simplement on prend
prises et une pièce et des pions plus
pris au racisme ou tu laisses faire
toucher 2 watts et peut-être même pas la
peine non peut-être tour c6 alors tout
son tour ses six à là encore mieux
puisque voilà je laisse je vais prendre
à six avec la tour voire même des six au
passage et en laissant le full hd vite
que la tour s'active et c'est vrai que
sur fond à 6 oui il ya peut-être aussi
des cavaliers h 30 je ferai peut-être à
voir
voilà la teneur en résultat le temps
quand c'est un thème que j'ai gardé en
tête pendant toute la partie et grosse
erreur à la fin certaine grâce et h3 et
là c'est matt
non il ya encore quatre ans et que les
quelques ruelles de m oui de natilia
tour g1 maths et épreuve car l'épreuve
de maths au sort telle mauvaise surprise
et sa gang ou et rétrospectivement ça
fait peur dans mes torts pas non là
c'était bien c'est pour ça je m'en jeudi
7 mai au tour ses sept s'étaient pas
indispensable doit-elle jouer les atours
anciens et je vais [ __ ] on assiste
directement
oui voilà où ils disent tu peux aussi
laissé la tour là à prendre avec le fou
de ce billet ne vous sera aussi bon tak
tak et là simplement pour ces sources ce
on prend les derniers pions on a quand
même faut pas oublier qu'en tous ont une
pièce de plus et on va en manger tous
les torts et l'abandon de toute façon
elle a abandonné sur tourcoing 17 ans
donnait surtout reprend 17
elle t'a fait confiance pour conclure
cette belle partie donc c'est quand même
pas mal si une partie d'attac
oui oui ça fait du bien
de retrouver son jeu des talus si elle
peut faire quand même faut dire elle a
pas réussi à faire illusion qu elle a
pas réussi à trouver du compte retrouver
des contres jeu donc ça ça te relance
dans le tournoi parce que ça te fait
trois points maintenant oui trois points
sur six sur scène qui est ça te permet
pas ce campus comme nino était bien
placé bon mais ça te permet de traiter
de la rattraper
même si tu lui passe devant je ne sais
pas je sais pas j'ai pas regardé
regardez j'ai regardé le classement et
donc pourquoi pas maintenant essayer de
faire un bon résultat vu que alors tu as
encore tu as déjà joué sophie millet
j'ai joué sophie admis rayar a déclaré
forfait
oui aujourd'hui je jouais nino donc il
me reste andréanne à bretaye scories
sérielle mon père sylvia oui et honda
safran ce cas voilà donc encore des
matches à jouer mais je dirais c'est a
priori des matches - - - de difficile
les matchs en dix matches mais un peu
moins quand même fait en tout cas il ya
plus de chances donc tu pourrais
pourquoi pas espérer un podium cette
année
en jouant serré et en restant concentrés
voilà donc voila c'était la tâche à
avesnes mesbah pour la première fois
cette année à angers et pourquoi pas
mais pourquoi pas le titre aussi tiens
rêvons rêvons un peu et on pourrait te
retrouver un peu plus tard au studio
pourquoi pas pour commenter une autre
doté belle victoire j'espère bien merci
nous avons rejoint merci merci nous
avoir suivi sur ce numéro diagonale tv
spéciale avec natacha benzema ici à juin
2016 je vous donne donc rendez vous pour
une prochaine émission diagonale tv au
revoir